hi everyone sal khan here from khan
academy welcome to our homeroom live
stream very excited about today's guest
superintendent austin buettner from los
angeles unified school district so
already start thinking about some
questions you might have for him and put
them in the message boards on facebook
and youtube below this video or next to
this video wherever it shows up and
we'll try to get to as many of those
questions as we can but before we start
into that conversation i will give my
standard reminders first of all that
khan academy is a not-for-profit
organization we can only exist with
philanthropic donations from folks like
yourself so if you're in a position to
do so please go to khan academy.org
donate also special shout out to several
organizations that have helped khan
academy uh really accelerate what we're
trying to do during the covid crisis as
you can imagine a lot of folks are
leaning on us more than ever that's made
our server costs go up we're trying to
accelerate programs so special thanks to
bank for america google.org
att fastly novartis and the many other
supporters of khan academy over the
years to allow us what we're doing but
we're still running into deficit so we
need your help
also one last announcement uh just
reminder of our podcast uh so we take
the interesting bits of our of our
conversations here and i suspect today
is going to be one of them uh and we put
into a podcast so that you can actually
uh listen to the homeroom
while you drive or do other things
without creating some type of a safety
hazard so definitely check out homeroom
with sal the podcast wherever you find
your your podcasts uh so with that i'm
excited to introduce superintendent
austin buttner a superintendent bootnerd
thanks for joining
so thanks for having me i really
appreciate you taking the time to have
this conversation
so maybe a good place to start is just
going to lay the land you are in charge
of the second largest school district in
the country highly complex job under any
circumstances but obviously under the
last six or seven months have been
especially unusual
i just love a kind of a background of
how have you handled this like what was
it like last march april as you were
just as the closures were starting to
happen how have you navigated through
the summer and how are you thinking
about it now great uh
we're in the midst of a crisis that none
of us have ever seen before but if we
remember where our north star the
constellation north star is for us are
which is student learning
support
for the families we serve
and making sure we take care of our
employees who do those first two things
we're going to get there
now as you mentioned los angeles is kind
of big and unwilling we have about 700
000 students more than 80 percent of
them are from families living in poverty
about 75 000 employees spread across 700
square miles so
much of what we need to do we need to do
in scale we need to be able to take an
idea and turn it into a reality and
scale
and what we've tried to do is respond
to those same set of priorities
we immediately converted our
school lunch
effort into a community food relief
effort we've now provided more than 65
million meals to hungry children and
adults the largest
school relief effort in the country
we've provided almost 10 million
items with that whether they're books
noise cancelling headphones recreational
sports materials
baby supplies with that alongside that
we made the effort to make sure we could
keep students connected like this with
their school community
so we bought computers
we worked in march alongside apple to
pull inventory out of their stores to
make sure that we could get our youngest
learners ipads
we worked with verizon to create a
template
that we could buy very cheaply or to
dramatically reduce price for internet
access that we could provide to students
and their families for free
you know we live for our students many
of them live in the wrong side of the
escaping digital divide we tend to think
of it as that area between south and
north dakota
where there aren't cell towers but
actually in many communities we serve
families can afford broadband so we set
out to do that as cost effectively as we
could
we set about training our educators in
what it means to teach and engage online
and we've had three rounds of that we
took all 35 000
through a basic set of trainings we
allowed another 15 000 to go for what
i'll call the masters in it and then we
did it again during the summer
we did that all without missing a day of
school by the way
to respond to learning needs in the
summer for the first time ever we
offered
summer school for every student in our
school district everyone
and we tried to take some creative
approaches and you and i had this
conversation before about what student
engagement actually looks like in this
form of teaching and learning
so we brought in different set of
partners james cameron took some of our
high school students on a voyage of the
titanic weaving in literacy math and
absolute engagement with fender music
we created virtual music classes where
fender provided free guitars we had a
thousand people participate in the
summer we kept it going we have 2000
more this fall
the creators of despicable me and secret
life of pets worked with us on animation
and so students learn to draw and tell
stories
and with snapchat we created book club
and as much as i might like recommend
books to our high schoolers alicia keys
over snapchat we reach students where
they are
and it was pretty exciting to see the
day we launched that within moments 500
of our students had responded to her
storytelling about a book that she's
reading or had read and they could
download it for free out of some
charitable funds we raised
500 students in the first just few
minutes so we've tried to do things
differently and i i think i was a little
bit late i apologize i was just coming
from taking covet tests the next chapter
for us
is we've set up a system to provide
testing for the covet virus and all the
contact tracing that go with us in
schools because we think it has to be
part of a safe return
for all the school community to campuses
so we have to do things different it's
part of the nature of it one of the
things i hope we do talk about is how
we're learning from this and how some of
what we're learning will make us in the
system better i think when we get back
to campuses but there's no substitute
for being in schools
absolutely and maybe you know there's
there's so much of what you just talked
about and some very cool projects i
guess you know reminding us that you
know being los angeles is a fairly
unique place
but but you know some of what you
mentioned the lunch programs the
especially you know trying to close the
digital divide or at least you know make
it not as much of an issue
i i'm curious you know we've been
hearing talking to superintendents
district officials around the country
that uh one i mean that's not easy i am
curious how you were able to get the
devices out i i've read other places
outside of our conversations you know
many tens of thousands or even hundreds
of thousands of devices y'all pulled off
but are you finding that there's still
kids that are disengaged even after you
you get the devices out there
uh
not easy to get devices so we looked
ahead you know the old observation one
makes when you see a toddler walk they
bump into things because they're looking
at their feet
you need to look down the road a little
bit so we looked down the road and said
okay in february we started ordering
devices we said
this could go this way they won't go bad
we'll figure it out in march oh in
february that's actually worth i don't
think anyone was i didn't remember
anyone really talking about school
closures in february so y'all were
thinking of y'all we're doing some
serious contingency planning okay yeah
yeah
now engagement takes many different
forms so the first measure we have is
every student connected when we started
in march we were short about 15 or 18 of
the kids within about four weeks 100
connected because we said first they
have to be part of the school community
then we started to measure what does
connected mean are they engaging in
classes do all of our different
tools and so to be clear you all got how
many devices did you have to get out to
do that i mean just logistically that
seems hard 15 of 700 000 kids you're
looking at over a hundred thousand
devices
who who when we had
uh
uh
hadn't connected but it's actually more
than that so it was hundreds of
thousands of devices and hundreds of
thousands of internet connections which
is why we again we had to reach out to
verizon and say can we do something
different here because
the bespoke one by one connecting wasn't
going to work we needed a wholesale
system to quickly get to that point
and then we started talking to our
partners khan academy amongst them to
say what how do we teach online what
materials can we supplement with so
whether it's zoom or nearpod as as
connecting or communication technology
or different apps that may be math or or
language focused we reached out to all
of them and said we need more we need
more from you we need to learn more we
need to measure engagement we need to
figure out what the efficacy or usage
use case is for all of these because for
us
technology had always been a supplement
it was never the main event
we took a quick inventory when we our
teachers were going through the
trainings were able to survey
there were more than 400 different tools
and technologies and use in our
classrooms that's too many as a
supplement great when it's the core and
the focus we had to figure out where to
place our bets which ones were most
widely used what our feedback from our
educators are and we continue to have
working groups where our teachers are
working alongside the technology
providers to give them feedback so as
the next generation or the next need we
have it's built into
the service they can provide for us so
we measure
connection
we measure time utilization we measure
assignments and one of the things that
you and i spoke when we first met a long
time ago now
uh how you're able to tell us just how
much engagement there was
on your platform in the various parts of
it amongst our teachers well that's very
useful for us because we know there's a
use case
the customers told us something and we
have a lot more
available to us
in terms of a digital footprint today
how we use that wisely
what the shortcomings are how that does
or doesn't compare
to a classroom setting you know those
are questions we're still unpacking some
of them i mean people say what's your
attendance
well we can measure physical attendance
okay now we assume a lot of things we
assume saul's in his seat in the
classroom and therefore he must be
paying attention to learning something
well that's not always the case the
converse may be true if small has not
logged on
well it might be reading a book might be
working on a writing assignment
and just because you log on i could turn
off and you could watch my screen with
my name i might be taking a nap one of
my siblings might be banging away on the
keyboard for me or i might be distracted
at home and dealing with other pressures
so
what we can learn digitally isn't always
you know signal of noise there's a lot
of noise out there we have to figure out
where the signal is
and what's a value to us as we work
alongside our teachers to get them the
tools they need and
help them learn how they can best use
them
and what does that look like right now
you know we're kind of a couple weeks
into this new school year now how does
digital learning look in la unified is
it pretty consistent are you seeing
pockets of excellence places where you
think you could see some improvement
uh so we're 90 almost 99 connected gotta
start there because we started a new
school year and so the high needs
population like we serve there's a lot
of transit a lot of new families
families have moved
uh we did a survey of families about
hundred thousand families
uh three quarters of the families we
serve have had someone in the household
blues work due to covet so the impact on
families is enormous and so we started
the school year with
mostly about being connected are you
safe and well do we know each other
because that's the foundation for
learning if you don't have that right
you can't jump right into the homework
assignment it's not going to work that
way so we got to the 91 level the next
is we look at are they participating
students participating in this type of
engagement is there dynamic
participation engagement between
teachers and students
we're also pretty high levels there
what's the daily attendance there's a
new state standard we comply with that
on how we measure attendance
i was just out of middle school this
morning i said 99 attendance kids are
attending they're they're part of it
now that engagement will differ by
community it'll differ by type of
student we know that
students who are struggling the most are
young learners i haven't seen anyone yet
show me how you can teach someone to
read
over a zoom call
our english learners those students with
differences or disabilities those who
might have been struggling before school
facilities were closed the challenge is
greater now for sure
the challenge is
greater amongst our highest needs
families so if you look at our
enrollment pattern compared to prior
years you'd see we're up in fourth and
fifth grade
we're up in high school
we're down meaningfully in kindergarten
so we had a bunch of educators
go into the community and try and better
understand that and we heard back
a couple of things we heard that
families struggling to get by
don't necessarily have the support at
home
we heard some families have given up
hope lost work
and they've left which is a relatively
expensive community in which to live in
search of an opportunity
and we've learned that some families
have said well kindergarten
my child's safe
they're in care whatever care might be
and until
students are back in a school facility
uh the imperative is not there to enroll
in california it's not law until a child
is six to be enrolled so we've seen
those challenges so i could tell you
kindergarten
engagement's tougher unless you've got
an adult with you kids aren't logging on
by themselves or participating by
themselves
high schoolers more capable learning
independently i was with a young man
this morning who's
had perfect attendance and is doing
great and he's a water polo player he's
he's got it all put together
but he's built that foundation along the
way and so our young learners english
learners students with differences in
disabilities we need them back in
classrooms as soon as it's safe and
appropriate
and what does the classroom experience
look like is it a bit of whatever was
happening in a physical environment has
now been transplanted to some
combination of video conference and then
you know assignments on on the khan
academies of the world or is there a lot
more variation
there's more variation i think you know
you know as well not better than many
that would be a mistake if we just tried
to replicate what we were doing it
wouldn't work first of all you'd have
eight hour zoom days uh and both
students and teachers would lose their
minds from that that's not a good or
effective way to teach and so what we're
seeing if
the spring was that you know try to
carry on
keep students engaged
but too late in the school year to
change much
summer was learning for students and
learning for our educators what can we
do differently how do we use the time
differently
and the new school year is more about
that so the engagement piece
is focused on the interactive and the
technology where
information might be found or a viewing
of khan academy might be done separate
from that
you find a little more structure in the
day and schedule which can help families
can help our aides and other
non-rostered
classroom individuals teachers to make
sure they can all participate so a
little more structure and schedule and
we're just getting into assessments
we are assessing all students to see
where they are with a low stakes
formative assessment of some sort let's
say dibbles for instance in
elementary for early readers
and that's a challenge you know dibbles
in a traditional first grade you can
probably get done in one day
assuming most your students are
are able to stay on task you don't test
for it i'm sorry you don't prepare for
it there's no training for it so you
want to see where they are and meet them
where they are
now take dibbles
to a zoom
where on any given day one of your
students may struggle with the
technology
they may be distracted at home may not
be quiet
there might be siblings or family
members who inadvertently give them help
or getting away
and
the patience and tolerance for young
learners to go through all of that
that's that's a tough journey so we want
that formative assessment because
students need the feedback their
families need feedback on on where the
work needs to be how to build on the
strengths and
try to address some of the challenges
but it's not so simple to say dibbles in
a classroom can go neatly and become a
dibbles online it's not that simple
yeah and that's related to a question i
have here from facebook kids that care
is part of their question is some
parents at my school are pushing back on
the amount of screen time and the use
and i guess in this case canvas as a
learning platform
what or have you all done anything to
modify the curriculum what learning
platform you know maybe the learning
platform maybe is not as relevant but
how are y'all um you know are are there
some guidelines on the amount of screen
time or is it still kind of learning
what families can handle because now the
parents are kind of the teaching
assistant so we have
we sort of have excuse me a minimum set
of standards
but it's going to be different
without question
all of the screen time limitations in
particular young learners have we have
to be cognizant of that
they can't
excuse me
so we have a set of standards
uh we leave flexibility in the hands of
the educator who knows best
you know saul may want to turn off his
camera that's okay if that's where saul
is we still want saul to participate
he's still hearing we know he's
participating so we we try not to be too
rigid and top-down we want to hear from
the voice of the educator in the
classroom
and
you'll see if you look at a schedule
you'll see time on time off so the
synchronous with some asynchronous time
and back to synchronous as opposed to
we're going to have three hours straight
of synchronous um
you have an engaged audience i know but
after three hours listening to us they
would all be asleep or they have turned
off their computers and and the same has
got to be recognized both from a student
perspective
and an educator perspective
so yes there have to be boundaries
around that and i think sometimes people
want to look at the measure of
synchronous time and say
more is better less is worse well
directionally right
but there there's no sciences you and i
both know on how much is too much
and so we're trying to go into that
carefully and recognize unique needs of
students because
some
will do better in this form some will do
better more independently and we want
teachers to have that flexibility what
they think is best for their students
and what about in terms of the the
number or the the number of either
subjects or the coverage of standards
you know in a normal school year you're
covering oftentimes six in some cases
seven subjects if you include things
like pe and art
and then obviously you know you're
trying to cover n standards in a year in
an english or a math class is there a
view to kind of free up that a little
bit to try to say okay this is the
really the must-haves and then there's
maybe some nice to have to do that
online and where that
real test will come no pun intended is
hybrid so a lot of talk about hybrid and
let's just unpack what that is or isn't
hybrid exists because you can't get
everyone back in the same classroom it's
not a choice and we willingly make you
have online or everybody back we all
want everybody back but health protocols
won't let everybody back at the same
time so you have to have smaller cohorts
which means some will be in a classroom
and some will be somewhere else accessed
online okay so that gets us to hybrid
now think of the implication
for
a master schedule and secondary complex
versus
elementary
elementary
teacher could be with some students in
the morning and the other half the
students in the afternoon and when the
students aren't with a teacher there
could be an aide a playground supervisor
there are other ways to make sure that
students are with us all day in
elementary
and the focus on the core happens half
day okay that's manageable and you can
keep a small cohort together for medical
reasons small meaning
12 students teacher aid they'll fit
within a classroom safely
if a outbreak of the virus to occur you
can isolate it to a relatively small
group so it won't spread to the entire
school it's elementary
let's go to the secondary more complex
schedule typical in our high schools or
secondary schools to six six different
classes
so 12
plus a teacher and aide
go on to six
the math will take you to two to 250
individuals
that one person could come in contact
with one or two degrees of separation
because you go from your you're not the
same 12 all the way through
so when we go back to schools
in a real hybrid not not a
uh
or i'll call let's say a medically sound
hybrid where we're keeping the cohort
small we're going to have to look at
that master schedule and say what's the
priority
of in-person instruction the rest may be
at school instruction but actually
provided by an educator who's online
because
we can't take you to sick all six of
your classes in person
because now we no longer have a small
cohort you've been around 250 students
one of you or your teacher were to uh
have the virus occur all 250 go home but
that's not
sound from health practices so we're
looking at that now and as we transition
at some point when it's safe and
appropriate los angeles it's not yet
when it is
we're going to have to look at that
complex master schedule and to your
original point there's the gotta haves
and the foundation pieces and then we
will supplement the others as best we
can
uh and not all of the requirements field
to be met in the same way we used to
meet them but we're in the middle of
pandemic and
the point we look at and say is
okay online is online
for almost all students
being back in the classroom is a benefit
okay
if we can only offer you online and
in-person math and english that's better
than online
it it will pale in comparison to what we
used to do six months ago when you could
have french and music and uh all of your
electives and everything else in person
as well but if we can't we can't and and
so the health boundary and the
instructional boundary have to co-exist
in the same program for students
you know it makes a ton of sense and i
cannot i can only imagine i mean
scheduling is hard during a normal year
i can't even imagine that the you know
the contact racing and the the cohort
size etc etc you know i guess two
questions in one and this is related to
one from
uh susan
garcia dominguez
hello superintendent bhuttner what rules
need to be rewritten for online learning
i'll expand that a little bit
for you know what has been
what has been the learning i mean you
mentioned there's been learnings this
year what has what do you think is the
loss what are kind of your fears here
that maybe the damage that has already
been done and that might occur over the
coming six months or so
and then what are silver linings if
anything of this maybe from some of what
the rule rewriting or whatever it might
be yeah it's so i i won't use the word
rule too much but i think the loss and
the and the potential benefits i guess
the losses
learning loss for sure
we spoke about already
a lot of research on what the summer
slide is
now students have been in online
learning but there's still been a slide
for many it's
not hard to
assume that's the case hasn't been
studied but let's assume that's the case
and as each week and month goes by
we're already at the six month point
where students have been in classrooms
so there will have been learning loss
for many
there will be
the social emotional side which is not
getting enough attention it started in
this country as a health crisis
is becoming an education crisis will
become a mental health crisis
and so many of the challenges we face in
society present themselves in schools so
we're expecting and planning for when
students are back in campuses
that some of the most foundational work
will need to be done around the social
emotional society
to allow educators to move on and start
to get into the learning loss and how we
not only catch up but take students
ahead
now we're trying to intervene along the
way we are doing one-on-one
instruction where we can do it safely
outside we've set up online tutoring for
free to students and their families so
we're trying to intervene where we can
but the loss in learning
the trauma and the challenge when we go
back to classrooms is going to be
enormous i mentioned earlier you know 75
of families have had someone lose work
that's trauma in a household which may
have already been struggling to get by
uh god forbid a loss of life or health
and safety issue with someone in the
family due to covet so that's coming
those are all
uh the deficits
now the challenge in the use of
technology
can and i believe will become
of some benefit to us not not it will
not supplant or replace
great
in classroom learning
but look at what we did with fender
and say it's an and the classes with
fender are teacher-led so our music
teachers are leading the classes we have
fender bringing in
their secret sauce bringing the fender
play app on top for students who want
more
and one and one is about five it's
amazing uh the work we do with alicia
keys and russell westbrook around
snapchat
is a different way because we think
about
the challenge in online is also an
opportunity challenging online is
students aren't with us they're not a
captive audience
so we've got to keep them engaged the
opportunity is to figure out how to do
that use different tools and
technologies meet them where they are at
least the key is meeting them right
where they are they're they're coming to
her they're actually not coming to class
they're going to alicia keys so if we
can take some of those skills and
learnings and bring them back with us to
the classroom
you know i hope the alicia keys snapchat
book club is around with us for a long
long time as this defender music class
and some of the things we're doing so
when we do get back to classrooms
we'll know a lot more about how we can
make the use of technology
an important part of the everyday
experience for all students
and we'll learn a lot more about how we
keep students engaged not just online
but actually in in a classroom today
and you know hopefully maybe this time
next year things are
close to normal or back to normal
how are you going to be viewing your job
then is it a lot of just you know well i
don't want to color your answer too much
but is it you know there's there's the
the learning loss you'll have to deal
with what other things and there's
things that you don't want to lose
potentially
yeah well let's uh i don't want to make
this a money conversation because i
think it's more important as a values
conversation what we have to do
to make sure our students have that
opportunity to learn and as you know so
well learning's cumulative so those
young learners who aren't building the
foundation skills and literacy and math
and critical thinking
will have a lifetime of consequence
unless we get on that
but there's a money issue looming too
and for whatever set of reasons
schools are the forgotten child as part
of the conversation about how we recover
from covet
the
nation as a whole has risen to the
occasion to respond to the needs of
healthcare community and that's great we
should
no one should be without whatever the
appropriate treatment is and those
clinicians on the front line should be
supported
the front lines are going to be in our
classrooms
at the same time we are facing the need
to invest more
to provide adult meals meals for adults
because they're hungry we should
to provide devices internet access where
we receive no dedicated funding for that
the cost of testing and tracing programs
sanitizing cleaning classrooms we
changed the air filtration system in
every one of our schools 80 million
square feet of buildings replaced the
filters we went from a merv 8 to a merv
13 we just skipped all the other nerves
in between and what merv 13 is the
filter is the same membrane as an n95
mask all that costs money
and so as we're transitioning from a
health care crisis
to an education crisis and the social
emotional seeds the students that come
with that
if there's not
recovery funding
schools are going to be in a world of
hurt because municipal budgets state
budgets where most school funding in
california all comes from the state
states under a lot of budget pressure
they've already said cuts are looming
and if the federal government or the
state government can't step up
at the same time we have to invest more
we're looking at budget cuts and the
intersection of those two things um it's
not promising
yeah no well i i wish i wish there was a
a rosier outlook but i mean that sounds
like a very real
set of circumstances that we're going to
have to struggle with over the over the
coming year well you know these
conversations always go a lot faster
than i i expect
and i know
i mean we just talked about it you know
all that you have on your plate and it's
it's not an enviable position but it
gives me comfort that you know folks
like yourself are are at the leading the
charge and and how we navigate this very
tough situation uh so thank you so much
superintendent buettner for joining us
today
thank you and thank you for having me
and thank you and your colleagues we
found the work you're doing at khan
academy invaluable it's become a real
not just uh option but a real necessity
for so many other educators to bring
into the work so thank you for the work
you do and all your colleagues
appreciate it
no well it's our honor to be able to
help thank you
well thank you everyone for joining uh
today's live stream i thought it was you
know i i
being a superintendent is a hard job in
any circumstances especially of a school
district the size of los angeles unified
with 700 000 plus students you could
only imagine how hard it is in a time
like this when when so much is changing
so it's really heartening i know
superintendent buettner from before this
conversation and i've always been
impressed with his work but um not not
not an easy situation to go in but i
thought it was really valuable kind of
understanding all of the levers
so with that you know thanks for joining
today some of y'all might have known
through social media i have a uh maybe
they mentioned it yesterday's last year
i i was sprinting with my son yesterday
and i have trouble with moderation and i
tore my right calf muscle
which is not a pleasant it's it it feels
just like it sounds
and it actually kind of pops it's
horrible
so that's why i wasn't able to make it
yesterday
but you know i'm always willing to go
through the pipe pain to have these
conversations so i'm doing all right now
much better i'm all loaded up on
ibuprofen uh but anyway thanks everyone
for joining and i look forward to seeing
y'all for our next uh homeroom
conversation
you